all right um
um
so ishida
you know she's at school
she wants to keep training she did the
right thing
she didn't go to the aikido club
that's gonna suck and she went to the
bjj club that is good that's the way to
play it okay
um
but
yeah she's uh
yes
i don't know what to do from side
control but
she's been trained in it
but it's not in your memory you see that
and a lot of you are experiencing that
you're trying to do guaza
and you got nothing to work with okay
so
before you get into the deep deep
psychology of the unfettered mind
you got to have the reps
and they have to be at depth
it is it is
not possible lord wanted
to gain the unfettered mind
without you passing fully through a form
phase and that means
you can do the forms
with the best of them
okay
and that means that you
remember that
do you understand
okay
so she asked for some review so we're
going to
use this opportunity because i know you
guys do not remember them
and i know some of you haven't seen it
some of the newer people okay
so um remember it's always about
attacking
from a position of advantage
and that will always mean to gain
control
and then you would do your attack you
can think of it as act
gain advantage
seek control
then the transaction the transaction is
the law or the submission or whatever
trying to just go for the submission
before you have control or before you
have advantage is going to give them the
opening they need to do the act strategy
against
got it okay
so
to touch base again ishida
um
you would follow the maximum of
position before submission that's act as
well okay
so when you have side control just the
basics again uh you want to be low on
the guy without crossing the point of no
return which is you have more weight or
too much weight across his spine such
that you are easily turned over
and now he has you
second thing
very common beginner mistake is you have
your butt in the air because you have
your weight on your knees instead of on
the guy so you you sh his your weight
should be on him
you're gonna have to open your knees
to lower your butt
third
no space any space you create he can
move into that space is empty space it's
in space
he would be following jiu jitsu
principles by moving into the in space
so i don't give him yin space so he
doesn't move into it okay so that would
be okay i'm not across the center line
um my weight is on him
but all this space here
gives him room to move so
tight
tighten your hand
next detail
a lot of his escapes
require
that this hip be able to move like for
example
um he wants to do elbow knee escape here
if he has space here at this hip he can
get this knee in and now he got out of
sight control
so
one way
is no space have that knee there so he
can't get in there
since we're doing ghee another way is
that you can grab
the ghee around his
buttocks area
and you can take that knee away
and your arm is kind of go ahead and try
it again your arm is duplicating that
same block
if there's no ghee and you want your
knee to do something else you can block
it here by posting your hand
and
he'll try it again and you're just
keeping that hand there
uh posting on the mat okay so key in
terms of no space
pay attention to the no space here
at the hip got it
okay so let's see you just get play with
those basics with your partner and then
we'll keep adding on to refresh ishida's
memory
all right so ishida's question was i
can't get to mount well again
there is a difference between learning
things in kihon which we call here
administrative
and then trying to do things in live
environments okay
so if you think about
your technique your kion
as a bunch of way stations
it's made up like the technique is you
got to do that then you got to get to
there and then you got to get to there
and you got to get to there do you see
that
but
the guy administratively is not
preoccupying the distance between those
two weigh stations so it's kind of like
you're in star trek and you beam in here
and then you beam in here and then you
beam in here and that's not gu
in gu it's like you're on a pilgrimage
and you go from this station and you
gotta walk to this station and it's
actually the walking part that is the
religious right okay
so
it's all the stuff in between
that allows you to get to the next weigh
station that counts all right
so
um
as i advise you ishida
you can't just go for the mount
because you're going to have to create
space to move out of side control and
that's going to create in space
and then he's going to use that to
create openings maneuvers counters
attacks of his own
so what you have to do is you have two
choices uh you get him to move
got it
or you wait for him to move but if he's
skilled he's gonna wait for me to move
okay so you have to know how to do both
got it
in terms of getting him to move there's
really two ways and again you want to
combine these two ways
so
one way is to preoccupy him with an
attack so he has to defend the attack
and then he has to move okay
the other way is to uh make him
uncomfortable where he is
with pressure than he wants to move to
relieve the pressure okay
in terms of the first one
the best preoccupying attack is striking
if you have a weapon it's pulling the
weapon it's gonna preoccupy him okay
but probably in a bjj club there's no
striking there's definitely no weapons
okay
so
we'll go over some basic attacks
at the beginner level you want to know
how to attack the arms and the neck area
because you're here controlling this
area okay so we're going to give her
one of each and for those
that know the
americana or the figure four
we're gonna reintroduce the details
which she does not have because she
forgot the technique on top of
everything okay
all right so
uh again the figure four is this one the
americana right you're here like that
the way that we do this here there's
there's all these little tweaks and and
things that work okay
learn them all but
our basic is the following
it's really a three-point attack that
you go through okay
um so first for the people you have seen
this technique right
figure four okay so we're just gonna go
on
you you've seen it all right so we have
one new person here okay so we'll just
learn the basic first uh we're just
gonna push it down
put my elbow on the ground near his neck
thumbless grips that means my thumb is
on the same side as my fingers
okay
come underneath his arm
grab my own wrist
keep his hand press pressing into the
mat
bring his arm towards his hip and lift
his elbow
to do the technique okay
um
i'll do it again
we're just going to push it down
put my elbow on the mat near his
neck no space
come underneath
thumbless grips on both hands
and
lift his elbow press his hand into the
mat bring his whole arm towards his hip
okay here we go let's get some rips on
that and then we'll get to the details
okay
so and the way that we're going to do it
is we're going to attack the outside of
the ball and socket joint or the bottom
socket joint itself
then we're going to attack
the
shoulder mechanism itself
and then we're going to attack the elbow
okay
so the way you attack the
ball and socket joint
is to pull this thing
in
to tighten this thing
like that
okay
so
i'm gonna go here and the first thing i
do
is crank this thing towards them
a lot of people will tap out there a lot
of people and then you don't need this
mad arm strength okay you're just
bringing it into your body all right so
i have to reduce that a little bit
or a lot to get to where i would take it
next okay
so from the ball and socket joint attack
i'm now going to attack the shoulder
mechanism the scapula mechanism itself
okay so i'm not going to pull it in so
tight and this is kind of the standard
americana so pressing down
lifting the elbow and sliding the whole
arm mechanism down towards the hip
you got it okay so first i'm pulling it
in and then that's what goes into the
shoulder mechanism and then
before i get to his hip i'm going to
attack his elbow all right
so i'm going to again loosen up the
first ball and socket attack
loosen up the
shoulder mechanism attack and i'm gonna
get to the elbow okay so it's loose i'm
not in tight on his neck and at that
point his hand doesn't keep traveling i
just twist his arm i twist this forearm
do you see that okay so when i get to
all three when i get to all three
there's not much movement that is
required you see that it's about a half
inch of movement which means i have a
better chance of getting that uh against
somebody as opposed to moving his arm
all this way that's a lot of room and a
lot of space and a lot of time
okay um
once you understand this uh
you can see there's there's the other
one do you see this right here
so you're you're struggling you're
struggling you can't get it you can't
just quit you're gonna get it right here
first
the first one do you see how i'm doing
that i just brought it in okay so to for
you to understand
that first part which is the tricky part
that's what we're gonna do okay
so
this arm is here
this arm is here so palm up on the wrist
palm down here
and you just bring it in towards him
okay let's get that in and then we'll do
the whole thing together that first part
is the tricky part without that in my
opinion the arm often gets loose and he
moves around and stuff okay let's try it
is your arm okay let me let me give
tristan
okay so i'm here
boom pushing it down bringing it in
first
and if that's not working then i start
going towards the hip and if that's not
working i leave the hand still and i
start to lift the elbow
um
that was just to demonstrate
the three moves okay
it should be
uh when i'm here like this no nobody
should see the technique coming on do
you get that that if you can train
administratively you're here like that
then you have a chance
uh when they're live okay so shoot for
that
and do not accept this kind of stuff
that won't work in when they're live
okay
let's try it
next one uh we'll go over so
uh basic
arm attack attack the arm right so for
example
um
i'm coming around
and i'm tacking his arm and he wants to
do something right
uh because you you know what's coming so
get out of it what do you do see he's
gonna do something else you get it
so
you know for example
eight yard pass where you push and you
go over and if you pay attention what he
did in his escape
he put his arm out
and now i'm over
not into the mouth because he's not
using his legs to defend against the
mouth
you see he took him out of the way as he
was going around okay
uh
attack the neck
okay so a very simple one
is this one
just get your
thumb inside
okay
especially
uh when you start to see
for example
i came over
i go to attack the arm
and he moved it around you see and now
it's on the other side
see that and so now his neck
is vulnerable so i'm going to come in
put your thumb inside
a lot of people will tap here this one
you're going to attack that trachea okay
but some people don't so first attack
the trachea like a paper cutter seen
those things okay
i'm here
paper cutter
if some people don't bring your elbow uh
this way
and they'll
oh
they're gonna tap out okay so again
he had his frame because a lot of people
are trained that way so
i'm going
warm he goes to escape good
isolate the arm
i'm using my head
and using my key so try to pull your arm
out so again following the rule of no
space
the arm has been isolated and now the
neck
is vulnerable
put your thumb in
grab the key
over start the paper cutter and if it's
not working
bring your elbow
up okay
let's try this one
okay so i'm going to ask you a question
where did the opening for the neck come
from
him trying to protect himself do you see
that it's not that that i'm here and i
start going like that you're not it's
not gonna happen do you understand so if
i want the caller if i want the neck
attack
what did i do
what gave the opening yes
he
protected himself but i'm going to show
you that's not exactly it so i go he
protects himself and then i go here no
that didn't work
you see what did i do when he protected
himself nicely i isolated the neck okay
so this arm his frame you can look at it
is i'm trying to deconstruct his frame
okay it's no different
than we're here
he's got a frame you see and i just
disrupted it with that first instead of
trying to attack here attack here and
he's open now okay
same way
i could over here poop up
that made him move but this time i'm
doing it with an attack okay
not a fake or fake
if he doesn't defend the americana what
will i do
the americana okay
so i'm trying for it
uh
thank you okay
again some of you have this like this
he's gonna get around my head
come back do you see any
i can't get it
so it's very important not so much this
part
as this part
so try to come around my head
it's this part that counts
so once you are starting
he goes around
drop your head
drop your head okay
on this one now his neck is isolated
again
i'm going to come
[Music]
this way
on this side
you see that and put the four fingers in
like almost like a fist choke okay
one reason you might do that is
it's this side that's open this key side
is closed
um
who knows why
you just want options
so boom
i come around on this side
four fingers in and then
i'm going to
do this inversely so drop my elbow down
on that side
and if you didn't tap there that's where
i roll this up
okay so
can you see that
attack he defends
trap
boom
i come this side
four fingers in
around
one thing you can do two here is use the
other arm and pull it even tighter and
do the same maneuver
okay
let's try it
your moves
are hidden in other moves it's a way to
understand what we're doing
if you do the obvious
they can defend against it okay
so remember the three pillars of combat
is
ambush slash surprise is one of them
speed violence of action you got it so
when a lot of you were doing this so
ishida might do it too
you're trying to get this in place do
you see that and you're never gonna get
that in place you can tell oh you're
gonna attack my neck okay
so
instead it just kind of innocently comes
around
here not even doing anything not till
you get everything in place you can see
that he's just doing whatever that's
when you come around
and pop that thing in so you don't reach
for that position from the final
position you come around where it's
obscure where he doesn't feel anything
and you get your fingers in there it's
not a fist joke as it is like a fist
choke which means it's not a fist choke
so don't start pushing in on this side
this side has nothing to do with it
you're coming around you could even
you want to really hide it okay and you
come around and it's like this
do you see and you wait and pop and then
you rip it around okay hide your attacks
so
again to
uh recap so that you understand the
strategy
um
not just the moves okay
remember
the moves are those kind of weight
station kind of points we need all this
in between stuff okay
um
remember we're playing a game here so we
took out strikes and we took out weapons
those are by far
the best things for
making this guy
move and create openings
to understand
so uh like the way that we do it right
uh i'll kind of hang out and he's gonna
do something because everyone always
does something right
if uh so he'll do whatever
right
and i start working my arm isolations do
you see that so it's he as he did that
move there
uh the arm that is under my
his left arm
it's got a lot of pressure on it so you
can try to pull your arm out
okay you see that so now all i have to
do
and there i am okay
or let's say
uh i want this arm
isolated over here
okay
so
he's here like this and he's framing and
i'll go again boom boom boom and there
is the
okay
you see that
um
or
we're here
right
and this arm is trapped in here
okay and
uh i'm going to take advantage of that
and get to my weapon
here like this and now he can't stop me
from drawing my handgun because again
try to get the bottom arm out can't get
the bottom arm out
and this arm
cannot reach over to stop that because
of how i have it out of the way so
you see it's not going to get there it's
trapped here like this and i can draw
for free
and
fire my hand
okay
um
but we're playing a game no strikes no
weapons
okay
so
um
the way you would do it
as i said
well you get him to move
but
he might be skilled he's like no you
move first you're not doing anything to
me i'm fine here do you see that okay so
i go to move like i'm gonna go to mount
and your defend the mount
oh sh
he got it in and so he keeps working it
and oh crawl crap
so
it's always better to use these
strategies
uh
make him want to move so to speak and
one way of making him want to move
for somebody who's not moving but is
waiting for me to do that
is
attack
okay then he has to move he has to
defend the attack
the second way i mentioned is pressure
makes him uncomfortable do you see that
and
pressure though
is is a lot of size dependent and a lot
of strength dependent
so if you're much smaller than that
person
if you have a good pressure game you can
still generate some pressure but if you
measure that relative to somebody who's
heavier than their
uh
partner their opponent
and you would rate it like a pain scale
you see you would give them that's a ten
and then the other lighter person with
good technique
they'll go like it's like a four okay
it is still important to know pressure
because you doing pressure in all your
attacks anyways okay
but the kind of pressure it won't ever
be if you're lighter and weaker it won't
ever
be the pressure that will do this
generating they want to get out of this
it's not comfortable do you understand
okay
um so try to work somebody around your
size you can be smaller than them you
just can't be a lot smaller than them
okay
and then also remember that even if you
are bigger pressure does involve more
strength output
than non-pressure it just does okay
so you would always have to measure your
reserves on how you're going along
through whatever match you're doing okay
so
um
if i am tasking myself
with
mounting and using pressure to open the
mount i want to create pressure
in that when he wants to move
he either bridges
or tries to turn away from me then that
opens the mouth
do you understand so i already showed
you when he turned away then his legs
are not
uh
defending by
keeping my mouth out okay and then when
when he bridges it's when so he he would
bridge do you see and i'm gonna get
really really tight on here and i'm
waiting for him to go back down you see
that so as he goes back down
that's when i am on i got kind of timed
that thing okay
um so
let's first look at how to create
pressure we'll give you several several
uh techniques to do this all right
um so again we'll go into administrative
mode
right
and the first one we're going to do from
side control
is
come around
lift up
go high
and come around this way okay
so i want to get instead of being here
i'm going to put things under him
put those things under him and then i'm
going to use those things to press into
him on the top okay
so here
roll
come up you can do it this way you can
get this other arm in there and now what
i'm going to do
is start to put my back into watch my
back
okay so i'm not i'm not resting anymore
i'm going to use my back and after my
back goes
i'm going to use my arms and then i'm
going to roll him onto this even more so
i go my back
then my arms
and then
my posture
see how i did that okay so that's our
first one
us here
boom roll on two you put it underneath
him come underneath that
go back
boom
your arms and then put him on top of it
okay let's try that yeah okay
okay so again a review
the principle is put things under him
engage your back then the thing that's
under him pull it towards you
and then
put it put him over it more okay
so
um and again he's he's much smaller than
me so if it's too much you just say tap
tap or tap okay but i'm just to show it
technically okay
so i'm going to come around
again no space like normal side control
i'm going to roll him up
so i can put my arm under it
under him and you get no space here
okay
and then i use the other arm
to to put the other arm underneath you
see
then my back
you see
then my arms do you feel it tristan and
then i roll this over
okay got it i want you to do it slow
like that
because different people have different
sternums and rib cages and things like
that okay let's go so we're gonna
increase the pressure and also it's good
to know how to increase pressure from
different positions okay
so um
i came around i came under him this time
i'm gonna use that arm to get under on
this side you see okay so i'm on this
side and i'm gonna do the same thing on
my back keep your head down my back
first
back first pulling him into me and then
my putting him on those hands okay
um another way you could do this one too
again the common rule is get things
underneath him
put your back into it
pull him into you
and make sure he stays on top of it so
i'm underneath right i could go
underneath this way too
see
and then my back
boom
and then put him into it
okay
go back
okay so next one
i like doing the first ones
like maybe i do maybe i'm going for this
thing right and yeah i don't know why
i lose my grip so look i'm in here do
you see oh
i'm in here okay
um
and i want to increase the pressure now
so i'm going to take the bottom arm
again
and i'm going to
have it be flat or i'm going to pick him
up
and then move him forward
okay now he's under
his respiratory meridian okay
and i do the same thing
my back
bring him into me
and keep him on me and we're gonna go to
the next one i'm gonna drive my hip
into those
floating ribs
into that uh arm that's on the back side
of his respiratory radiate so
here
okay
next thing i do
pick them up
move them around
so you come on the other side over here
okay
going on there
i need my hip
to drive his floating ribs
into that arm underneath him you have to
do this slow some people's ribs might
break okay so i'm doing it slow
i'm going to keep the hip
on light to show you what i do with his
upper body as i do this thing okay
so it's a matter of driving the left hip
into the floating ribs and as i go
i'm picking him up
okay so i'll do it slow and try to
not have so increase pressure on the hip
again do it slow like that so nobody's
ribs crack okay
[Music]
all right
so i'm trying my thing he does is
whatever and there it is right there do
you see how that that happened okay and
i i can just cut to that one so again
it's a combination of the two moves
right
here and i'm gonna get
i can maybe even try there's the first
one
okay
so
when you when you feel that happening
yes there it is you see
then i'm in place okay and i'm in place
get everything where i want it to be i
have the pressure game pull
over okay what and the way that i use
this
is because of the strength cost
i i only look for him to uh not be
breathing
where he's comfortable so pressure to me
is
i'm attacking his respiratory system so
he's breathing too comfortably right now
so i work my back
and that is that's where i'm at
and when he wants to breathe because
everyone wants to breathe right
um
that is what
i i float at right so i can feel this
diaphragm moving
so i'm gonna start doing more pressure
okay
and here
i'm here and i could get the tapas is to
me it's too much strength right so
when he starts countering people trying
to breathe dude
get yourself out
do you see it i give him that space
these what'd he do
he bridged
you see they say he bridged
right because he can't do for example he
can't do elbow nego he can't do it
because i'm controlling the torso he
can't shrimp so he's bridging so i make
him bridge
okay
uh meaning
don't blow yourself out
you're using it to set up
what you needed for the mount
okay
so
rashida you're tasked with the mount
because
you get more points from going from side
control to mount
for us here we're interested in the
strategy
and but we do different tactics to
utilize the strategy okay
all right
thank okay everyone